scp-2571 also known as craglewood Park
is a euclid-class anomalous phenomenon
manifesting as a recurring childhood
memory of a non-existent theme park this
memory affects approximately 0.05
percent of the global population with a
higher prevalence among adults raised as
an only child the method of transmission
remains unidentified and recent evidence
suggests that the number of affected
individuals may be increasing
subjects Afflicted with
scp-2571 recall visiting craglewood Park
between the ages of 4 and 12 commonly
reported features of the park include
anthropomorphic tree and plant
characters a lack of adult supervision
and Calliope music playing in the
background memories of cracklewood Park
typically resurface once treatment
ceases the precise nature and origin of
scp-2571 and craglewood park continued
to be subjects of ongoing investigation